(lively music)
- These three individual
pigments can be combined
to create various shades of browns.
- [Narrator] This is Kelly Dobos.
- I've been formulating
products for over 20 years.
I've worked for Bonne Bell,
Jergens Lotion and PURELL.
Color cosmetics is one of my specialties.
- [Narrator] And now she
teaches cosmetic science
at the University of Cincinnati, so...
- Today we're gonna break
down the ingredients
in ILIA's True Skin Serum Foundation.
Aloe leaf juice.
- [Narrator] There are
over 35 ingredients listed
on this $54 foundation.
- Polyricinoleate.
- [Narrator] But let's
start with pigments.
That's where those iron oxides come in.
ILIA did not respond to The
Wall Street Journal's request
for comments on any of its ingredients
but Kelly says those
iron oxides are key here.
- In foundations, we use
four primary pigments,
which are red iron
oxide, yellow iron oxide
and black iron oxide, as
well as titanium dioxide
to tint the foundation.
Iron oxides are exactly like they sound.
They're basically rust.
Red iron oxide, of course,
is probably most familiar.
Titanium dioxide is used
to tint the foundation
to different shades, but it's also added
to increased opacity.
The higher coverage of a
foundation, the higher level
of titanium dioxide.
See how it turns into brown
when we can mix them all together?
- [Narrator] All of these
ingredients are considered safe
by the FDA.
However, titanium dioxide,
which is in many foundations
in sunscreens, has recently
come under scrutiny.
- Titanium dioxide can be
a carcinogen by inhalation.
- [Narrator] California's
Prop 65 requires businesses
to warn consumers
about titanium dioxide
when it is in the form
of airborne particles, not
in these liquid foundations.
- What we know about titanium dioxide
is that it is safe when used
in cosmetic formulations.
The concern really comes
from industrial exposures
to workers who might be in
manufacturing situations.
- [Narrator] Iron oxides
have a moderate safety score,
according to the Environmental
Working Group's Database
on personal care product ingredients.
They're found in over 7,000 foundations.
- The iron oxides are
a very smooth feeling.
We don't want them to
settle where you would have
to shake your foundation
every time you want to use it.
- [Narrator] In order to
prevent the oxides from settling
in the foundation, chemists
will dissolve the pigments
and a liquid that has yield value.
Something like this ingredient
- Yield value is the ability
to suspend a particle.
Hand sanitizer contains a polymer
that provides yield value.
You can see that it is
suspended in the solution.
Another aspect of
foundations is, of course,
the main solvent.
Water is the best known
solvent to most of us.
It's a very low-cost ingredient.
The ILIA foundation, however,
uses aloe leaf juice instead
of water, which has to be harvested
and processed in order to
use in cosmetic products.
So that adds a significant
cost to the formulation.
Aloe is about 98% water,
making it a good substitute for water.
(Kelly chuckling)
- [Narrator] Another
underestimated ingredient.
- I think fillers often get a bad rep.
They sound like they're not
doing much in a formulation
but they're really important
to balancing the feel
of a product across the
entire range of shades.
- [Narrator] Fillers help the pigments
and the foundation spread evenly.
Kelly says other makeup brands
have used talc as a filler.
- The talc used and
cosmetics is highly refined
to remove any traces of contaminants.
However, there have
been some controversies
where talc has been
contaminated with asbestos
and that has caused it to be
removed from many products.
- [Narrator] The FDA says it continues
to test for contamination
in cosmetics containing talc.
ILIA does not use talc.
Its ingredients list rice
hull powder and boron nitride.
- Boron nitride and and rice
powder are more expensive
than talc, and they have
additional properties,
like the boron nitride
provides the optical blurring.
- [Narrator] This optical
blurring from the boron nitride
helps create an overall
smoothness in the face.
- So this line represents the
particle of boron nitride.
We have incoming light
hitting the particle
and it can be reflected at the same angle
or it can be reflected
at many different angles
and that's what the
optical blurring effect is.
- [Narrator] There are
also skincare ingredients
on the list.
- As cosmetic chemists, we
have three different strategies
for moisturizing the skin.
Those are using humectants, emollients
or occlusives in a formulation.
A humectant helps absorb
water like a sponge
and an emollient or occlusive
forms a protective layer
over the skin like this wax paper.
If we look at the label
for the ILIA foundation,
we have hydrating ingredients.
We also have emollients.
Glycerin is extremely
effective at hydrating the skin
and it's also very cost effective
and it feels pretty sticky
to the touch as well.
- [Narrator] The order
of ingredients matters.
- Cosmetic ingredients are listed
in descending order of predominance.
That means the greatest
concentration of ingredients
are closer to the top of the list.
The ILIA Foundation contains ingredients,
like niacinamide, allantoin and bisabolol.
These are bringing
benefits to the foundation,
like skin tone evening,
and additional hydration.
The ingredients with
skincare benefits are closer
to the middle of the list
in this formula, indicating
to me that there are
at efficacious levels.
- [Narrator] And much like lotion.
- Foundations are typically
emulsion products.
That means we're combining oil
and water or silicone phases.
In the ILIA foundation,
we have polyglyceryl-2
isostearate as an emulsifier.
Hydrogenated lecithin can
also be used as an emulsifier
- [Instructor] And an ordinary
ingredient also helps.
- You might be wondering
why sodium chloride,
ordinary table salt is in this foundation.
Well, it's really doing
a pretty important job.
It helps stabilize the particles
in the emulsion so that
they don't coalesce
into larger droplets and
destabilize the formula.
But it also helps lower the freezing point
so that the material's more
stable when it's transported.
- [Narrator] Once the
foundation lands on your shelf,
preservatives are responsible
for keeping the products
safe from bacteria.
- Different preservatives are efficacious
against different types of organisms.
We have yeast and molds, bacteria,
so we often have to use multiple
to achieve broad spectrum protection.
Each time you dip your
finger into your product,
you're basically adding bacteria to it.
And as cosmetic chemists, we
do studies to simulate that.
We call that a preservative
challenge test.
- [Narrator] There are other things
to note on the overall packaging.
- ILIA markets itself
as a clean beauty brand.
Clean beauty is not defined
in a regulatory sense in
the cosmetics industry.
So many retailers and brands have come up
with their own definitions of clean beauty
and it tends to focus
on more naturally derived ingredients,
as well as ingredients
with known safety profiles.
- [Narrator] Cosmetics are not required
to have FDA approval
before going to market,
but the FDA does provide
guidance when it comes
to product safety.
- Safety first.
I always bring up lab safety,
especially when I see a picture somewhere
of a scientist and they're
like staring at a beaker.
And I'm also like, nobody stares
at a beaker up in the air.
You put it on the table. Sorry.
(interviewer chuckling)
(playful music)